get the ball out of his hands
levine hits a three i say again get the
ball out of his hands
because that's what he's capable of
doing big time players make big time
plays double a
[Applause]
that's a tough shot malcolm brogdon 23
tonight
we're tied with ten and five tents to go
[Music]
justin holliday defends and they play
him straight up
former teammates at some point i've got
to look at dublin and that's what they
did they doubled it
they were looking to double it missed
the shot yep
and we go over time pacers have all five
starters in double figures
25 for savannah's 23 for brogden
he made a tough shot too it really is
and
the pacers nobody got a body on that
and it's a five-point lead
gotta shoot it yeah you're right there
in the paint you gotta look to shoot it
oh they went away from me he ball faked
him and then thad was the guy who ball
fake tooth that is young
in that center spot and they threw in
the ball many as indiana missed around
the rim tonight
it has been quite a few chris
kobe white and a seven-point
chicago lead i was gonna say come give
him a place to throw it
and mcconnell got all the way to the
basket he's got 19.
this is going to be difficult because
they've got ball handlers
temple steps inside the arc and hits the
jumper
well they're covering the faces up nice
shot there that's a tough one to get